[Music]
identity and access management or IIM in
Google cloud gives you fine-grained
control over the permissions that users
have today we're going to look at group
membership and the resource hierarchy to
understand how you can allow users to
access resources let's start on the iam
page where we can see the permissions
for the different users on a project and
our project named my project the user
user at T se Jun X net has been granted
the storage object viewer role this role
allows a user to list and download
objects from storage buckets but does
not allow for creation or deletion of
any objects this role is granted to the
user in the projects IIM policy so it'll
apply to the whole project and all
buckets in the project let's take a look
at those buckets by going to the cloud
storage page
if our user were to go into the your
bucket three to one bucket they'll be
able to view all objects because of the
storage viewer role at the project level
as we said before they won't be able to
upload a new object or delete an
existing object the same behavior can be
observed on the command line if the user
runs GS util LS all the objects from the
bucket are listed when the user tries
deleting an object with gsutil RM the
operation fails with an error message
that the user does not have these
storage objects dot delete permission so
far so good let's take a look at another
bucket named my bucket three two one
here our user seems to have options to
delete and upload objects we can see
this by running GS util RM and seeing
that the operation succeeds what would
cause this difference in behavior
between the two buckets here we can see
that both buckets belong to the same
project so our user should have the same
storage object viewer role the user
should have received a permission denied
error when trying to delete the object
to investigate this kind of issue the
organization's security admin can use
the iam policy troubleshooter let's head
to the I am an admin page and then click
on policy troubleshooter here you'll be
able to see details on what permissions
a user has we can put in our user's
email the full resource path and the
permission we want to investigate if you
want to see more details about policy
troubleshooter check out the
documentation after we click check API
call we can see that the user has the
storage object admin role at the bucket
level due to being a part of the group
at TSA June X net group storage object
admin lets users do more than just view
objects they can also create and delete
them even though the user has the viewer
role on all buckets in the project
having the admin role on this specific
bucket overrides that in order to use
the policy troubleshooter you'll need to
have the ability to see policies across
the organization such as with the I am
that's security reviewer role you also
need access to see group memberships for
any groups that you want to list users
for check out the documentation to see
more about using the policy
troubleshooter and which roles you'll
need
[Music]
you